thank you very much Sean and thank you
for being here
during the next half an hour or so I
will speak a little bit about what we're
doing in terms of Time series research
and deployment
today we're gonna be speaking about a
specifical field in the time series
world called hierarchical forecasting so
for one minute close your eyes and
imagine that you are working for the
government in Australia you are in
charge of the whole Ministry of Tourism
you are the minister of trade and
tourism in Australia
and you constantly get or you one of
your jobs is to answer the question how
many tourists are going to be visiting
Australia and the different regions the
next week the next month the next year
and this is a classical time series
problem where you are trying to predict
future Behavior based on past
observations where you are using also
features like the trend and the
seasonalities of the series but also
including exogenous variables like
economic variables weather and so on
these questions are important because
while you are working there as minister
of Tourism you get called by different
people that are asking you how should we
staff the airport how many people should
we put this weekend or next month how
will the economy grow nationally but
also at a state level
this is important because Australia has
seven states all states have Governors
and then you have zones and you have
regions and you're interested in
forecasting and understanding and being
able to predict forecasts for the whole
of the country but also for each of the
different States territories and regions
this is a classical hierarchical problem
where you have in total 555 series that
are divided by the different levels in
the hierarchy so what would you do as a
working for for that office one thing
that you could do is try to predict at
the lowest granularity what we called
fine-grained forecast and then add them
up so for example you would forecast
Sydney Blue Mountains Hunter and then
add the mom to New South Wales and then
to the total of Australia
so the problem with that is that as you
can see here in the graph normally lower
series with more granularity are very
noisy are very sparse are what we call
in the field sparse time series that is
they have a lot of Serial values so it
doesn't matter which model you use it's
going to have a very hard time
understanding and predicting it so if
you take that and predict it and then
sum it up you're going to accumulate
errors and when you reach the top it's
going to be a very bad forecast you
could then do top down you could try to
forecast the whole of Australia and then
by some weights maybe country size or or
total shares of Tourism divide them for
each of the different regions the
problem here is that yes the top series
is well behaved in the sense that it has
clear patterns of seasonalities and
Trends but you're gonna miss very
important information of the lower
Series so that doesn't really work
neither so the third thing that you can
do to try to solve the needs of every
one of the president that it's
interested in the whole country the
governors that is interested in the
different regions is to forecast all the
different series all the 555 series
which isn't that much but if you are
working in a large organization and you
need to do hierarchical forecasting for
for example skus that add up to brands
that are up to categories that are to to
something else then that could scale
massively also if you work in finance
and need to construct portfolios that
are coherently hierarchically coherent
that's also going to be a problem so the
first question that we have is
okay now I got appointed how do I
forecast hundreds or millions of a Time
series and the solution is to use and
probably and that's what we recommend
you one of the open source libraries
that are out there today we're going to
be speaking about three particular
libraries that we created at nix lab
next Lab as Sean was saying it's a
company a startup that is building an
Open Source Time series ecosystem we
created from the very beginning
libraries that had in mind scalability
so you could distribute series across
different machines with backends such as
spark coiled or Ray but also a libraries
that from the very beginning were
focused on making life easier to
practitioners and for us it shouldn't
really make a difference if you forecast
1 10 or 10 million a Time series so
today I'm going to show you how to use
ml forecast which is the library that we
created for machine learning models we
also have statistical econometric models
at Deep learning models and in less than
20 lines of code I'm using this machine
that you see here we we were able to
forecast the 555 Series in less than 15
seconds in this case feeling a classical
light GBM model so the only thing that
you need to do besides importing the
libraries now I'm at line seven is to
instantiate this ml forecast class you
just pass a list of models here we are
using a light gvm but you can really put
whatever model of the SK learn family
linear regression nearest neighbors you
could also use a HD boost and we will
take care of Distributing that
computation natively for you after that
you just specify the frequency that we
are going to be using and here you can
really see the power of the ml forecast
library in terms of feature generation
machine learning models require some
feature engineering normally you have to
do that outside of the pipeline here you
can simply Define the lags and the
different window operations that you
want to implement like expanding mean or
rolling mean for every two years in this
case which is 24 months
then to fit and forecast you simply call
the fit method specifying the data frame
that you're using the ID and here you
can have as many series as you want the
time column the target column and if you
have exaggerous variables you can
include them too and then predict the
next 12 observations that is the next
year by calling the predict method so
now we were able to create 555 Series so
it seems that everything is fine we have
done a good job as a Ministers of
Tourism however we got a very angry
phone call from the president saying
that the series that we gave them for
the national level don't add up to the
series that he got from the state
Governors and the problem really is that
the forecast at different levels don't
add up and they how could they if we
didn't like create a reconcile strategy
we forecasted and trained at every
different hierarchy so maybe things are
not that fine after we created the 555
so what is the optimal solution and the
intuition is very simple the intuition
is to forecast at all different levels
and then reconcile in such a way that
the forecasts are of that's that's up
and that's what we call it the field
hierarchical reconciliation and
the idea is that a hierarchically
reconciled forecasts have this structure
with the bottom Series in this case the
the four dots as you see here the fourth
series add up I add up to the next level
and then to the total of the series
obviously this graph can't be as large
as you want and as complex as you want
and I'm going to introduce some notation
this is not really that important that
you follow every single step of the of
the equations but the intuition here is
that you can't describe this
hierarchical structure by means of
Matrix notation so here in this Matrix
every row it represents a row of the of
the graph so the first row has all ones
that means it includes all the different
bottom series then the second row is an
aggregated series it includes the first
two these ones the third one this two
and then you have one particular Row for
every bottom level so one here one here
and so on
this is this is what we call the summing
Matrix of the hierarchical structure and
this is a very powerful intuition
because if you create a summing
structure or the summing Matrix of your
hierarchical time series and you
multiply that matrix by your base
forecast then you get what's called a
hierarchical reconcile bottom-up
approach so what I just explained is
would be the same as as doing the first
approach where we forecast base levels
and then we create a the structure based
on summing optimase levels so what's the
difference with hierarchical
reconciliation and the difference is
that you do a two-step approach where
you first take yes all the forecasts at
the base level but also all the
forecasts at the different hierarchies
and then you multiply that by a matrix a
projection Matrix p and you try to find
that Matrix in such a way that it
minimizes the variance between or the
errors between your forecasts reconcile
forecasts and your original forecasts
and and in reality this is like summary
of what all hierarchical strategies are
doing they are trying to find that
projection Matrix so you can have the
best possible reconciliation strategy
there are different approaches today
we're going to speak about the
statistical approach with this which is
all about either minimizing the variance
between your forecasts and reconciled
forecasts and the True Values or
reconciling minimizing the errors
between what you are forecasting and the
reconciled forecasts this tradition of
thought was started by some prominent
practitioners in the time series field
the guy there on the second right is Rob
Hinman he's one of the most important
practitioners in the field and he and
his team started creating different
methods so beyond some classical top
down and and bottom-up approaches there
are two very famous methods one is
called Min trades that was published by
uhurija
and here the idea is that we are gonna
find the Matrix P which minimizes the
trace of uh this variance here so the
idea is how do we find such a b that we
get the least variance between the
actual values and the forecasted values
and to do that we could obviously try to
build that manually but that would be
computationally very expensive because
we would have to take the interactions
of all series with all series giving
that we're trying to estimate these
variance covariance Matrix so instead of
that you can use other approximation
methods to try to compute that like for
example OLS
the other intuition is not to minimize
that variance but to minimize look at
this part of the equation to minimize
the average between the actual values
and the reconciled forecast which is the
same as multiplying HP times the the the
y y hat which is the forecasts and here
we're taking more of an empirical if you
want approach to error minimization this
method which is called empirical risk
minimization reconciliation strategy was
proposed by a tajep also in 2019 and and
and here after doing this we just do
some regularization with lasso so it's
not very volatile well that sounds
really hard especially if you are
working as a tourism minister in
Australia and you are not really that
into linear algebra and that's why we
created this Library called hierarchical
forecast so practitioners could start
reconciling forecasts without doing all
the complicated Matrix operations that
are required for these methods the only
thing that you need to do is to pip
install the library and we offer a wide
variety of reconciliation methods like
bottom up top down middle out ERM Ming
trace or some probabilistic ones like
premview and bootstrap and how this
works and I'm gonna guide you through
the code again it's not more than 20
lines we Define the hierarchies we set
country country State country state
region then we generate with the
aggregate function the the three values
that are important for us the data the
hierarchical data frame the important
summing Matrix h i h sorry that I
introduced at the beginning and some tax
we're going to use this in the next step
and here in the next step we instantiate
the hierarchical reconciliation object
by simply passing the list of
reconcilers that you want or that we
would like to use so we can use as many
as we want obviously that are available
in the library but it's really easy to
specify the ones that we that we would
like to to test and after that we just
call the reconcile method on the
hierarchical reconciliation object by
passing the base forecast that we
created the summing Matrix H that we got
from the last step the tax and the
fitted values that we got during the
training set and after that we would
have a completely reconciled forecast
that minimizes errors and also minimize
or minimizes variants and that would
make hopefully the president very happy
and also the governors because
everything would match up
but now
we encounter a problem namely that
forecasting tasks are really more often
that not probabilistic problems you are
not that interested in just finding one
point in the future you are rather
interested in trying to understand the
possible distribution of future values
to take decisions on their uncertainty
and and this is important because
normally errors are not distributed
evenly in the sense that it's probably
worse if you are a little bit below the
actual value and if you are a little bit
above this is because if you are below
then maybe the airports are understaffed
or hospitals don't have enough people
and this could cause a real logistic or
health problem if you're a little bit
above then you're a little bit
overstaffed and yes you paid that extra
cost but it's definitely better to be
overstaffed and understaffed and the
same is valid for classic retail
problems where having lost sales is a
lot worse than being a little bit
overstocked on certain items
so it would be great to integrate
probabilistic forecasting into our whole
tasks and trying to predict tourism
flows in Australia and now that sounds
hard and the reality is that you just
need to integrate three lines
hierarchical forecast and ml forecast
and really all of the libraries of nyxla
are natively probabilistic you just need
to define the confidence intervals with
conformal prediction
you just have to pass the levels in the
same code that we showed you before and
in as easy as that you can get a
forecast that are probably listed that
are probabilistic if you want to
reconcile them you just need to pass
this argument here where you specify the
levels and then you get probabilistic
forecasts that are hierarchically
reconciled taking into account the
underlying probabilities
so
I showed you uh what you could do with
two libraries of the Nyx lovers we
started seeing how to forecast many
different series using many possible
models very efficiently we also showed
you how to reconcile them and then we
introduce the concept of probabilistic
forecast and probabilistic
Reconciliation this last let me see how
much time I got
okay this last 10 minutes or so we're
gonna be speaking about some of the
research that we're conducting at nixlr
and this is us trying to push the
boundaries of the field uh to be honest
in in our practical work we have seen
great results with what I have showed
you and I would recommend you if you're
excited to try this out to start with
statistical or machine learning methods
and then move on into more complicated
deep learning models but I wanted to
share some of the stuff that we are
thinking about
one of the problems with classical
reconciliation approaches is that it has
very strong assumptions about the
underlying distributions most of the
cases the reconciliation methods and
even the models if we're talking about
statistical models like arimas or other
Auto regressive ones are very strongly
opinionated about the normality
assumption and this is problematic
because if we assume normality then the
confidence intervals are symmetric and
then you can see there that we have
negative values for a series that can't
exhibit negative values there is such
there isn't such a thing as negative
tourism in Australia so that's a problem
the the other problem is that this
approaches are univariate in the sense
that they don't take into account the
relationship between the different
series and this is very important
because this series about the real world
they obviously follow certain economical
economic intuitions like complementarity
or substitution so probably if someone
visits Sydney he might also visit
canvera because it's very close but he
if you visit Sydney he's not going to
visit Tasmania and vice versa this is
also the case for a classic retail where
you have a good that substitute each
other and goods that complement each
other so it would be great if we could
somehow bring this relation multivariate
intuition into into the models the third
problem is that if you start having
really really big data and you start
having many hundreds of millions of
series then maybe training a local
univariate models it's going to be hard
because you need to distribute across
many different computers and there
aren't many when there are there aren't
as many computers so it's a complex
pipeline
the solution that we are thinking and
that we are proposing is what we call
hierarchical mixture networks and the
idea is that we are introducing a
flexible and efficient multivariate
probability loss into the neural
networks that we have made available to
the different packages that I will show
you
the main
advantage of this is that with the
introduction of this mixture meshes we
can't expand a vast collection of neural
network methods in a single framework so
the idea the mathematical idea and
tuition behind this is that if you sum
certain mixtures like for example
gaussians or
poissons then the sum of questions
discussion distribution and the sum of
poisson distribution is a poisson
distribution what we say here is and
let's focus here is that if you have a
hierarchical structure with C is the sum
of a plus b then if you sum up of the
distributions of A and B and A and B
have gaussian or portion distributions
then C will also have a gaussian or
poisson distribution and we have made
this loss all available for poisson
mixture meshes for gaussian mixture
meshes but also for very important loss
functions like negative binomials that
are particularly relevant if you have
counting data which you don't have
negative values and thankfully we have
reached the maximum number of equations
so I'm not going to introduce any more
what I'm going to show you now is why
this is relevant in terms of the
empirical results that we have gotten
from the research here you can see the
confidence intervals of a naive approach
where we are doing naive bottom up this
is we are adding the probabilities in a
normal way and as you can see the
confidence intervals are very very white
they reach from zero to to 100. this
means that if we want to be like
completely confident that the ARP
airports or hospitals are going to be
properly staffed then we would have a
very a wide range of Staffing if we
include a
through the concept of composite
likelihood these correlation groups if
we include the intuition through the
mixture measures and the correlation
groups that the series are related then
we get intervals that are a lot sharper
so you can see here they range from 0 to
40. so this would give us a much better
stocking or Staffing strategy we are
running some tests on reproducing those
results but we have gotten great uh
preliminary results so far and why why
is this particularly cool at least for
us
because now you can do hierarchical
forecasting with your favorite deep
learning model in a single integrated
framework so this time it must be really
hard
but as you can expect it is not hard and
this is the anticlimactic part of it and
we made it so or at least that's the the
idea behind neural forecasting so that
you could start playing with this
forecasting models uh easily so you have
to install neural forecast neural
forecast is a collection of different
neural forecasting methods it has a
recursive neural networks it has a
Transformer based architectures some of
the models that we have published like
the nbitzx and the end hits and it it's
really useful with also a wide variety
of of tooling around it so I'm going to
show you how this would work if we
wanted to train a classical lstm with a
poisson make sure mesh by the way we
don't recommend you using lstms in Time
series tasks they are very famous but
they don't really perform that well
and besides importing the different
classes and models and distributions
what we need to do is really just
instantiate this model where we defined
the loss here we're using a poisson
mixture mixer mesh then we instantiate
the model telling the package that we're
going to be forecasting 12 Horizons in
the future that we're going to be using
this list of models that we're going to
be using this sum in Matrix h i h sorry
that we defined before this is the group
level that we're passing in this sense
we're assuming that series that belong
to the same state are more correlated
than series that don't belong to the
same States so here the underlying
assumption is that there is a
geographical relation between the
variables
and we're using a bottom-up
Reconciliation strategy after that it's
really just the same we passed the dot
when we instantiate the neural forecast
class and called The Dot fit and Dot
predict models what if we wanted to
include another model let's say a neural
hierarchical interpolation model that is
one of the of the things that we created
and have gotten great results well you
just need to do the same you call the
model in this case we're instantiating
uh the model with a gaussian mixture
mesh loss and everything else is really
the same we just pass the list of models
here and we can create in a couple lines
of code we can train two important deep
layering models that are by construction
hierarchically coherent
so wrapping up
we started by forecasting at all levels
we showed them how you could be
reconciling hierarchies using different
statistical methods we then introduced
the concept of probabilistic
reconciliation and at the end we showed
you some of the things that we are
tripping on namely hierarchical nature
networks which we called hint if you
like the talk I would really appreciate
it if you could show some love on on
Twitter if there is on the QR that takes
you to to our Twitter account I will
leave that for one second
see if everyone is taking just phones
out
there are some links to the to the
libraries too so you can start playing
around with them there are so tutorials
and work throughs and if you're
interested in the academic part of the
things this is one of the papers we
publish with the people that I showed at
the beginning from Monash also please
read this book by the master Rob Hinman
and George atanasanopoulos and here are
some references and
I think that's that's the talk so thank
you very much for being here and
listening
[Music]